other projects after let's say yes say
that this is it for review let's say
that there's the final episode and let's
say your character dies let's say that
all happens ok
what would you move on to next well I
have written a script for a pilot about
a character that I've actually done on
this show named Dalton Wilcox the cowboy
poet I've done Dalton Wilcox on this yes
yes yes I remember really like I
remembers yeah one guy your agents here
so don't and Wilcox the cowboy poet yes
and you think that this could be what
could it be a series could it be a movie
oh it could be anything
koan and it could be then it'll be the
biggest thing that ever happened in the
world no it's it's because yeah Domo hey
he's a cowboy poet he believes he is
plagued by vampires that are trying to
kill him it's just a belief that he has
why can't you have a normal house whole
time I've known you you can never have a
normal thought it's a cowboy poet who
thinks who thinks he's plagued by
vampires constantly killing suspected
vampires
yeah well it's perfectly normal it
happens all right yeah would you like to
see some Dalton Wilcox no I wouldn't
okay folks that's all the time we're
glass that's right folks
Wilcox I've been referred to by myself
and sometimes others as the poet
laureate of the West and tonight I'd
like to share with you some of the wit
and wisdom of the West that I'm so
famous for having chronicled in my book
you must buy your wife at least as much
jewelry as you buy your horse and other
poems and observations humorous and
otherwise from a life on the range wow
that's a long title Dalton I I wanted to
make it a lot longer but I got here from
the publisher this is my most famous
poem this poem won the Pulitzer Prize of
the West okay here it is called no such
thing rather it's more prestigious than
directed this one's called that Lonesome
cowboy okay a cowboy is a lonesome man
there's none more lonesome in all the
land he rides atop his only friend his
horse a companion on whom he can depend
his woman may be white miles behind him
sadness and desperation may find him but
a cowboy who is wise will turn to the
earth to lend him solace and even mirth
he'll dig a hole with cracked scorched
hands pour in all the water that hole
demands until that hole is moist just
right the earth will never put up any
kind of a fight
his cries of joy no one will hear in
case I am not being clear I'm saying
that cowboy is gonna hole in the ground
we all do it that's what I've found any
cowboy that knows that Lonesome he'll
confessional and Virginie well if a
cowboy seed worked like other seeds
there'd be Cowboys growing everywhere
[Applause]
you call him poems are often open to
interpretation but I have to tell you
right now that's a poem about that's
what it's about
we know that abundantly clear a lot of
time people say what's that a metaphor
for it's not a metaphors about I do love
this man I don't know why but I do love
it
you